DC empanadas is closed for the day like
many of our restaurants and shops in
Washington and here at bidwell the head
chef himself is doing their cooking John
Mooney employs 19 people in his kitchen
most of them are from Latin America I
told them I expect you to strike and a
couple of people said they wanted to
come but everybody else I told them you
take off it's necessary the strike came
to show just how important immigrants
are for the United States in its economy
in the restaurant industry immigrants
make up nearly twenty-three percent of
the national workforce therefore they
want their presence to be felt by taking
to the streets these protesters also
wanted to voice their disapproval of
presidents Trump's immigration policies
I'm here to protest the Trump
administration and everything they stand
for my community doesn't agree with what
Trump's trying to accomplish and we're
just trying to show that that we're here
to protect our community and stand up
for our community just this last week
700 immigrants were rounded up detained
and are being processed for deportation
and that is not a priority here in this
country but the government has stressed
the necessity to deport criminal illegal
immigrants however activists and
attorneys are critical of the rates
saying they are going too far leaving
undocumented immigrants with anxiety and
fear it scares me it terrifies me I have
relatives who are undocumented and my
heart stops every time I get it call for
them because I don't know what's going
to happen to them the workouts are about
overcoming fear and being hurt more
demonstrations and protests have already
been announced
you